does ipad west 16 fix the biggest issues
with the m1 ipad pro and make it the
best all-in-one portable computing
device on the market well surprisingly i
think overall yes but there are still a
few very glaring real world issues that
apple didn't address that you need to
know about in this over one year long
term review i will be covering my
experience and what has changed since
apple launched the m1 ipad pro some
major misconceptions about ipad's new
stage manager and extended display
features and my thoughts on ipod os 16
as a whole and then of course is it
worth buying an m1 ipad pro or if you
should wait for the m2 ipad pro which is
coming up soon the m1 ipad pro is the
undisputed best tablet on the market and
by a long shot the only close competitor
is samsung's tab s8 ultra but the
snapdragon chip doesn't even come close
to m1 and the old display gets destroyed
when you factor in the usability of its
dim very reflective display especially
compared to the 12.9 mini led with
amazing anti-reflectivity coatings it's
an engineering marvel packing in an
insane amount of world-class hardware
into such a thin lightweight design
where else can you get a camera setup of
this quality level including lidar and
face id which is ultra fast and many
times just authenticates automatically
and where else can you get a 13 inch
120hz color accurate portable display
capable of full screen 1000 is sustained
and 1600 nit peak brightness with a
built-in battery to power it for many
hours for this price not even counting
the computer components storage
excellent speakers and so on the reality
is nowhere which is why with ipad os 16
apple fixed one of the limitations which
was sdr only with sidecar but we now
have full reference modes for use as a
connected display for pro hdr work thank
you apple this screen not only smokes
apple's new studio display but matches
my 6 000 pro display xdr but with twice
the refresh rate all while not
overheating and dimming that some people
thought it would because it is so thin
when they first released it i was a bit
worried about display blooming but over
the last year the times that i have
noticed it were few and far between and
although it does suck to notice it i
just had to remind myself that if this
was an lcd i wouldn't notice a glow
while watching high contrast hdr movies
and dark rooms but all of the blacks
would be that same shade of grey all the
time and then comparing to oled i
wouldn't get that amazing pop of
highlights especially for hdr the only
thing that compares is apple's own
high-end macbooks that use the same tech
but at much higher prices and with less
portable designs because of this the
12.9 inch ipad pro is still my favorite
device to watch movies on the go and the
quad speakers sound fantastic even
beating out the new m2 macbook pro go
ahead and take a listen for yourselves
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now i don't have the 5g model since i
have great tethering with my mobile plan
but if you need it that is something
that you still can't get from a macbook
as well as having the touchscreen and
apple pencil support for note-taking
drawing and much more oh and of course
that aforementioned face id as well as a
tablet that acts as a supplemental
device to your mac this thing is a 10
out of 10 but it's also extremely
expensive now the first 12.9 inch ipad
pro launched at 799 dollars now the
cheapest one is a thousand ninety nine
the first keyboard case was 169 dollars
now the one apple wants you to buy is
350
and of course the second gen apple
pencil costs more as well and it is
crazy that people complained back then
that it was too expensive now of course
it has gotten way more powerful
especially with the m1 chip and
thunderbolt but it still makes sense why
after dropping at least sixteen hundred
dollars for the base larger base spec
with accessories everybody was expecting
a good software update to come out with
ipad os 15 the month after that the m1
ipads launched and as you know everybody
was extremely disappointed apple dropped
the ball hard and i wasn't the only
critic with my reviews of the ipad and
ipad os 15. now being able to rotate
iphone apps and move widgets around was
great and all and then finally knowing
how long we'll take for a transfer was
great but we didn't need the heavily
marketed m1 chip to achieve that the
biggest issues that people had for years
were still unaddressed like external
display support still mostly being
limited to mirroring with large gray
bars on the side all while the ipad
itself could resize any app on the fly
to your desired split view layout and
with that forcing people to spend 200
extra on top of the storage upgrade
price to pay for the 16 gigs of ram
that's tied together if they wanted more
than one terabyte of storage while at
the same time only allowing apps to use
five gigs of ram just like before when
ipads had a max of 6 gigs thankfully
there was enough backlash and pressure
the apple removed that limit and fixed
it but unfortunately the myriad of
external drive issues were not fixed and
some still aren't with ipad os 16. for
example we got that crazy thunderbolt 4
port but if your drive wasn't formatted
you needed a mac to format it first
whereas android tablets could do that
six to seven years ago and since there
is no eject button if anything is being
written or accessed to the drive it
could corrupt and it would no longer
mount this has been an ongoing issue for
me in the last year with some drives
getting corrupted more often and
unfortunately even with ipad os 16 this
has not been fixed now apple makes a
huge deal about unmounting before
ejecting in mac os but they don't even
allow you to do that with the ipad the
most secure way i found is to manually
close the files app before you eject
your drive and hope that no other app is
accessing it with that something else
that nobody is really talking about is
how slow transfers are with the m1 ipad
pro compared to an m1 macbook with ipad
os 15 10 gigabit per second external
ssds would only connect at five gigabit
per second and transfers would be even
slower and then thunderbolt drives would
also transfer way slower than it to a
mac so did ipad os 16 fix that
nope it took me 33 seconds to transfer a
10.8 gigabyte file to the ipad pro
compared to 13 seconds to my mac over
usb type c and then 17 seconds using
thunderbolt compared to just five
seconds on my macbook air and for those
that say it's because ipad storage is
slower nope it is actually faster than
the m1 macbook air with the identical
capacity apple spent nearly 22 billion
dollars on r d last year working on
things like the apple car and vr glasses
but can we please just fix the external
hard drive support for ipads that you
can spend nearly three thousand dollars
on now of course we have what stole the
show stage manager which is why i just
changed up my setup to show you guys now
we have been wanting a more capable
multitasking setup which allows for a
desktop-like experience for years now
but especially since we got the m1 in
the ipad now some people are still
disappointed but personally i am very
happy with how this works and i think
it's because some people have some
misconceptions first off all you do is
you pull down from the control panel and
you enable stage manager
at that point we go into a full
different setup i have some of these
apps that are
full screen here and we have our dock on
the bottom and then our different
layouts and pages for multitasking on
the side you can quickly shift between
them i mean it is very versatile now
what some people complained about is the
fact that
this takes up a lot of space right we
have that dock we have this sidebar it's
not very clean and minimalistic well
what a lot of people don't know is you
just pull down and you can literally
disable that and then disable the dock
at the bottom and even if you don't
disable that dock if you go ahead and
adjust one of these pages and you can
adjust this any way you want and then
you pull it down that dock automatically
hides to give you more room now there's
a ton of flexibility with the set if you
can have up to four different apps open
you can have multiples as well let's go
ahead and open up safari over here
there's our browser we can actually
split these up we can actually have
multiple safari browsers opened up like
this
so you can customize this any way you
want to including just turning off stage
manager and getting back your regular
split screen so it is very versatile and
i see very little downsides now as you
guys could see right now as far as
external display support which is the
second half
we're still having this mirrored view it
looks identical to what i'm seeing with
those bars
now what is going on is the fact that we
don't have anything connected and apple
wants you to buy one of these for ipad
os 16 and stage manager so 350 bucks as
soon as you go ahead and attach your
ipad right away bam we have our external
display support now this is not the only
way to use it i'll explain how in just a
sec
but after this is open you have a whole
nother dock over here so even without
stage manager enabled i am able to go
ahead and open up and bring my tabs in
here i can launch different apps and i
can have some apps open here others
opened up on
my external display now there are still
bugs as you guys can see it does crash
every once in a while
but overall the experience is really
good and then of course with that apple
also added in the ability to go into
your display settings and adjust your
zoom so if you want more space just like
on a mac you can set it and then you'll
have more usable screen real estate so
overall i'm very happy with this now for
those of you guys i think it sucks being
tied to the keyboard and having to buy
that well there's actually a guy that
made a really great video in depth about
stage manager that connected a regular
mouse with a little dongle and it goes
right into the external display and it
works great so you don't have to have a
magic keyboard attached now personally i
tried with apple's magic mouse and even
though it does attach it does not make
it work so i don't know if you just need
a dongle or how exactly that works but
we can see that you don't have to buy
the magic keyboard now with that the
displays that are supported right now
it's kind of buggy but people have even
gotten the ultra wide displays to work
and it does work properly so apple is
working on all of this with this beta
setup so overall i have to say even
though that's not an exact mac os type
setup it's still clean it still allows
for all your apps and you have a lot of
flexibility so i am very happy stage
manager along with proper external
display support really make the ipad pro
a pro device and as long as you're happy
with the apps available for ipad this
could be the best all-in-one portable
computing device that can run as a
desktop setup for when you're at home
now of course we have the controversy
about siege manager and the external
display support only working on m1 ipads
and the excuses that apple has given
multiple times don't make sense since
memory swap isn't available on the base
ipad air the 64 gig but it still
supports this feature but you know what
i'm not going to get really in-depth
into this issue after this video you
guys can watch my ipad os 16 video and i
get into a ton of detail proving on why
this is apple just getting people to buy
an upgrade to the m1 model overall after
a year of use and ipad os 16 this tablet
is better than ever and if you can
afford it you will be very happy it took
over a year but apple has fixed most of
the issues so maybe one more year from
now with ipad os 17 it will be perfect
check out the ipad os 16 issues video
right over there and click above to
subscribe if you guys want to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
thank you guys for watching this max and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]